we were forced in the beginning i wish i  could say we were geniuses and said  we're going to start our own company you  know  that's not what happened you know in the  beginning we went to every single label  and every single label shut the door on  us  um the genius thing that we did was we  didn't give up  we didn't say because these guys  you know we use that what do they know  approach you know we  we didn't give up at that point i think  that would you know that was the genius  thing we did we started selling our own  cds and we built their own buzz and then  the record company came back to us so  now we had um  a different negotiation  you know it was in the same artist  label relationship now we retained  ownership in our own company  and it was the best thing for us